Good job trying to match each construct with each operational definition. For
depression, someone's score on the Beck's Depression Inventory, could be a way
of measuring and defining depression. For hunger, grams of food consumed. For
stress, levels of cortisol, which is the stress hormone. For anger, this could
either be number of profanities uttered per minute or even ratio of minutes
spent smiling to minutes not smiling. The difference is that ratio of minutes
spent smiling to minutes not smiling would be a better measure of happiness.
Because if it's greater than one then you're spending more time smiling. So the
higher this ratio, the happier you would be. So this would be a better measure
of happiness. So for anger, a better operational definition would be the number
of profanities uttered per minute. Some operational definitions aren't so good,
but this is just an example. Health, could be resting heart rate. Obesity, body
mass index. Effort, minutes spent studying for an exam. And brand loyalty, the
number of products purchased per year from a particular brand. So these are all
operational definitions which allow you to measure each of these constructs. And
after being able to measure these constructs, we can analyze them.